did you know that the water you drink is
actually the same water that dinosaurs
drank over 65 million years ago
it might be hard to believe but your
water is actually really really old in
fact water on earth is much older than
the dinosaurs scientists estimate that
the water on earth is at least 4.6
billion years old
and the amount of water on earth today
in lakes rivers oceans glaciers even
under the ground and up in the clouds
it's about the same as it was millions
and millions of years ago
that's because water is recycled it just
gets used again and again
and that brings us to the water cycle
which is how water continuously moves
from the ground to the atmosphere and
back again and as water moves through
the cycle it changes form
in fact water is the only substance on
earth that naturally exists in three
states
solid liquid and gas
have you seen water in all of its
different states
maybe on a hot day you'll add some ice
which is water in its solid state to a
glass of liquid water or maybe when you
take out some food that you've heated in
the microwave you'll see steam coming
off of the food which is water and its
gas state as water vapor
when you think of water you might think
of the wide open ocean
over 95 of all the water on earth is in
the ocean so this is a great place to
start with the water cycle
here energy from the sun warms up water
on the surface of the ocean enough to
turn it into water vapor this is called
evaporation
this water vapor is less dense meaning
it's lighter than liquid water so it
rises up and up into the atmosphere
however as the water vapor rises the
temperature in the atmosphere cools
in turn the water vapor condenses into
tiny liquid water droplets or
as we see them clouds
this is called condensation
air currents then move these clouds all
around the earth
as a cloud collects more and more liquid
water droplets the water may be released
from the cloud pulled down by gravity
and then returned to the ocean or land
as precipitation like rain if it's
really cold though the water drops may
crystallize and become snow
the snow will fall to the ground and
eventually melt back into a liquid and
run off into a lake or river pulled down
by gravity which flows back into the
ocean where the whole process starts
over again
but that's just one path water can take
through the water cycle it's like a
choose your own adventure
instead of snow melting and running off
into a river the snow could become part
of an icy cold glacier and stay there
for a long long time for thousands of
years
or
rain can seep into the ground and become
ground water where it's then absorbed by
plant roots
in turn through transpiration the water
absorbed by the plants can transition to
water vapor and leave directly through
the leaves via tiny holes called stomata
and return to the atmosphere
or
instead of being absorbed by plant roots
the groundwater can work its way to an
underground aquifer or a lake river or
even the ocean
there are many different paths for water
and the water cycle can be very
complicated
but it really comes down to something
very simple
the amount of water on earth stays
pretty constant over time and moves from
place to place
sometimes transitioning between phases
depending on things like weather
geography solar energy and gravity
now we know that water is essential to
life on earth and fresh water is an
especially limited resource for a
growing world population
changes in the water cycle can impact
everyone through the economy energy
production health recreation
transportation agriculture and of course
drinking water
and that's why understanding the water
cycle is so important
that and it's pretty cool to know that
you drink the same water as dinosaurs
did until next time